痛いと言ったっても いつまでも足が痛いわけじゃないんです
足に心が入っているんだから痛いんだよ
足が曲がったんだから痛いわけじゃない
それだったら曲がるたびに痛いはずなんです
足が曲がっちゃうと痛いんだったら
それは心の問題ではありませんかもしれませんよ
その方は足は曲がりませんだから
私の足が弱くて曲がりませんと
アーライトライって言っても硬くなってるんだと
曲がりませんだからね
だから足を組んでいるんだから痛いんですよというのは
もう何の根拠もない話で
足を組んだんだから痛いんじゃなくて
そこに心が入り込んで嫌味を作ってるんだから痛いんであって
それは それは事実なんです
例えば 血液の流れが悪いんだから冗談じゃないんです
血液の流れが悪くて 物理的な何かだったら
これ大変に明確に見えるはずなんです
それだったら血管でも破裂して爆発しちゃいますからね
そんなことはないんです
もうとにかくほんのちょっと血液溜まっちゃっても
もうここからパンプしているんだから
それはもうちゃんと出ていっちゃうんです
血液の流れが止まっちゃったら人は死んじゃいますから
だから時々そこは血液の流れが悪くなると
それは痛みで痛感する
あるいはしびれだと感じたりする
いろんな感じで感じたりする
だから物体として見れば
痛みも痒くも何もないんだと
折っても曲げてもどうってことないんだと
で この物体に対して心は何を認識するかという
それによって痛みも楽も苦も楽も生まれてくるんですね
耳があるんだからうるさいわけじゃなくて
心があるんだからうるさいんです
耳があるんだからうるさいと言うならば
全ての人類にある場所はうるさいはずなんです
でも うるさいっていうそのある場所は全ての人類にうるさいわけじゃなくて
ある人にうるさくて ある人にうるさくないんだと
そこでその場所においてうるさいという概念もある
ある人にとってはずっとうるさいわけじゃなくて
ある時うるさくて ある時うるさくないと思ったりするでしょう
だからはっきりしているんです
これは心の問題だと その場所にある特定の音の問題ではありませんと
その場所に音があるんだからうるさいわけでもなくて
そこに住んでいる人に耳があるんだからうるさいわけでもなくて
その音を認識する心によってうるさいかそうでないかと
その波が生まれていくんだから
そこで物質の世界と心の世界の働きが明確に分別
分別 分別して区別して知られるようになると
かなり心は落ち着いてきます
その段階なんですね このディッティスッディっていうのは
それでやっとディッティスッディが
見の症状が現れ始めるんです
それだけでは物足らないんです
さらにこの このナーマとルートでルートとして見えるようになっていれば
大体伝統的にはこの定義の世界
仏教はもう定義だらけだから
この定義の世界でありまして
一つ知っているということは
大体これラッカーン・ダッサ・パッチ・パカパ・ダッタン
基本的には 4つ あるいは 6つなんですけどね
6つ  7つとかいろいろありますが
まあ大体 4つぐらいの角度で一つの現象を定義しなさいと
この 4つの角度は何ですかと
角度というんですかね
例えばあるものに我々は何か名付けちゃいますね
あるいはあるものを他のものから区別するでしょ
そうでないと我々は知識ということがないんだから
例えばこちらはこれ缶コーヒーですよと
とも 他のすべてのものからこれを区別するんです
この缶コーヒーはこれ一つしか
世の中に存在しないんです
たった一つしか存在しない
どんな現象もそんなもんなんです
どんな現象もたったそれしか存在しないはずなんです
だったら 一般的な定義ではできないはずなんです
缶コーヒーを定義するという
全ての缶コーヒーの定義になるかもしれない
なってしまいますけど
ある面では缶コーヒーというのはこの缶コーヒーはこれ一つしかないんです
で そうすると難しいんだから
まあこの缶コーヒーはなぜこれ一つしかないかって
そこは明確に知って それで似ている特色を持っているものも同じ缶コーヒーだと決めてしまえば
もう知ったことになるんです
そこで これは缶コーヒーだというために
これしか持ってない他のものと区別できる明確なものを特色というんです
これパーリ語でラッカナというんです
で 仏教用語ではこのこれは自性とかくんです
自分だけ持っている性格
性 大乗仏教では自性を否定しますけどね
だからこの大乗仏教の知識が入っちゃうと
ちょっと混乱する可能性はあります
で 初期仏教とテーラワーダとかね
小乗仏教の世界では自性を認めるんです
そのその現象には自分の特色あるんだと
そうでないとどうやって現象と言えますかね
このマイクロフォンにはこのマイクロフォンだけに限っている
限る事象があって この小さなマイクロフォンには自分だけに限っている事象があって合うんです
それは何でしょうかと
ちょっと言いにくいかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりものを知るという場合は
まず特色を知る それは番目
二番目 Function
働きを見る なんで働き見るんですか？世の中でものはあるわけじゃないんです
世の中はすべてただの働き
ダイナミズムですね 動きなんですね
いわゆる停止している何か
もの 実体 物体あるというわけじゃないんです
我々物体というの何か働き持ってるんだからなんです
その働きがあるんだから
それは他のところにぶつかって変化を起こすんです
それで あ こういう働きでしたよとわかるんです
だから一番大事なのは
この働きということ パーリ語でラッサというんです
RSA 例えば なんでこれにマイクロフォンと言いますか
黒いんだから 机の上に置けるんだから
じゃないでしょうに 何か仕事しているんです
その仕事をもってマイクロフォンになるんです
なぜある鉄の塊に車というんですか
その働きなんです 何か仕事をしている
その仕事をやってるんだから
そうなっちゃうんです
だからどんなものも 働きなんです
物ではありません だから番目の定義は
定義というか 理解してほしいのは働き
どんな働きしますかと
ラッカナ ラッサ 例えば
おにぎりにはなぜおにぎりと言うかと
そこは自分だけ何かを働き持っているんです
おにぎりとバナナと あの
間違うことは絶対ないでしょ
おにぎりだと思ってバナナ食べてしまったと
ということはありえないんです
おにぎりはおにぎりの働きを持っていて
バナナはバナナの働きを持ってるんです
そこでおにぎりの写真がありますと
間違って食べてしまったということはありますか？絵に描いた餅を
じゃあ 絵に描いた餅と実際の餅はどちらが
違いますかね？絵に描いた餅はそこを自分の働き持ってるんです
それは決して餅の働きではないんです
だから絵に描いた餅もそれなりの立派な存在であって
自分が一つの現象として堂々と生活しているんです
何も欠けてないんです
で 餅自体は自分で実際に堂々と存在している
自分の働きを仕事を持って
そこを混乱する我々は色々哲学を作ったりする
絵に描いた餅は意味がないんだとかね
なんで絵に描いた餅に意味がないんだよ
意味があります それはちょっと誤解しているんです
皿に入れている餅と同じだと
こんなくだらん誤解していると意味がないと言えますけど
そうでないと そう そんな誤解は生まれません
絵に描いた餅には 絵に描いた絵としての働きがあるんです
その絵を見て我々は何か感じるとかね
いろいろあるでしょうに
皿にある餅を見たら その餅が違う働きを仕事しているんです
だから 二人とも完全にもう自分の仕事をしている立派なもの
現象なんですね だから一応瞑想しちゃうと
その世界はじりじりと感じてくるんです
で  道元禅師の正法眼蔵も
その世界 このカンカー
ディッティヴィッディの世界をとことん説明しようとしているところなんです
じゃあ 次のステージも考えてみると
道元禅師さんもそこら辺はまあ感じている
いたかないかと これから理解できると思いますけど
だから道元禅師否定するでしょ？餅と絵の描いた餅っていうのは
これ同じですよと 違うと思うのはおかしいんだと
すごい哲学だなとみんな感心するだけでわかってないでしょうね
なんででしょうね 本物の餅と絵の描いた餅は同じだというのはね
わかりませんね 絵に描いた餅はどうしても食べられませんし
食べてもお腹が空いている場合は何の意味もないし
それでも偉い偉大なる道元禅師は同じだと言っているし
わかりませんね やっぱりすごいと
わかりませんというのは道元禅師はすごいと
だからそういう話を聞いて私は笑うと
もうヒューマはいっぱいあると
この世の中に そんなことでその人を褒めたってもね
自分のバカバカらしさを表現するだけのことでしょうに
だから私はものすごく嫌い
ものすごいいろんなことを言われましたからね
私はそこら辺はもうこんなことですよと軽々しく言って
そんな冗談あんたにわかるわけないんだと
彼が言ってるのは 絵に描いた餅が絵に描いた餅としては堂々たる存在価値があるんだと
何も欠けてないんだと
これは皿にある餅と誤解しちゃったら
絵に描いた餅はいろんなものを欠けてるんですね
香りもないし 触れも触ることもできないし
食うこともできないしという欠点だらけになっちゃうんです
なんでそれ欠点だらけになったって
このバカもんが皿にあった餅と錯覚しちゃった同じだと
だからそれは凡夫の世界で区別ばっかしで
もう欠陥ばっかし見えちゃうんだと
仏法の世界ではそう見えません
全部同じですよと 仏法においては全部同じですよと彼がはっきりと言うんですね
だから仏法の立場から見れば
絵に描いた餅は立派な完全たる餅であって
さらに上にある餅もそれまた立派な完全たる餅である
だからって道元禅師絵に描いた餅を食べたんですかね
それは食べません それでまた一休さんとかね
いろいろ話がいっぱいもありしね
それ全部禅の世界でね
まあなんて言いますか
絵に描いた猫でもネズミを捕まるんだったらそれでいいんじゃないかとかね
だからそちらで言ってるのは
仕事さえしてくれるならば
それで完全だよと だから仕事自体が大事なんです
例えばネズミを捕まるという仕事は
猫という言葉で象徴するある品物がやるならば
猫を捕まる品物が猫なんだ
ネズミを捕まる品物は猫なんです
そこはもう土で作った猫か壁に描いた猫かと
そこまでいく必要はないんだと
そうやって物事を働きで捕まってみるんです
世の中にあるのは働きのみ
そこでこの犬の猫の話やら餅の話を持ってくるのは
ただ皆様をからかうためなんです
別にちょっとからかって笑って笑いたいだけのことで
私ではないんですよ 私の例えではありませんから
私はたとえ言ったらもっととんでもない例え出しますから
で それでもって真理を語ろうと思ってるわけじゃないんです
この偉い方々は ちょっとからかってふざけて遊んでるだけなんです
ああいうことで で 本当に瞑想の世界になってくると
この絵に描いている餅とか
ああだこうだ そんな世界ではありません
そんなこの美学的な まあ音楽的みたいな
この美しい世界とか そんなことも何もないんです
でもそこから発見したものは
俗世間に何か言おうとすると
いくらでも冗談が言えると
人をからかうことはいくらでもできるんだと
だからストーリー書くんですね
壁にもう何か描いたところで
猫の絵描いたところで
全部ネズミたちが逃げてしまったと
それで一般人はもういらそうに
どういうことかな 不思議かな
おそらくあのお坊さん
一休さんにすごい超能力あったんじゃないかなとか
もう思い存分騙されて
だからストーリー書いた人が笑ってるんです
そちらではある論理があって
働きで決めなさいということを言ってるだけのことなんです
そういうことで ものを認識する場合は
二番目の定義の場合は二番目は働き
三番目の言葉はパッチュパッターナという言葉なんですが
これ日本語で現状と書いてるんです
それはだけはちょっとこの説明しにくいんですが
現状はじゃないと思いますけどね
ここ現状ではなくて このパッチュパッターナっていうのは
このものがあるということは
自分がそのものを認識しているということなんです
何かあるということは
私が何かあるという場合は
その意味は その私はその何かを認識しているんです
そうでないとどうやってあると言えますか
わかりますかね そこら辺は
あるという言葉は認識という言葉なんですね
自分が認識している そうすると反論できますよ
もし私言ってることは理解できるならば
いろんな反論 じゃあ本当に実際にないものもあると言えるんではないかとかね
例えばあるというと それは実際にあるならば
神様がいるというでしょ
だったらいるんです というふうに反論できない
で ここに缶コーヒーがあると私が言うと
私はこれ認識しているんです
何かを認識しているんです
その何かを認識して それは缶コーヒーという言葉で表現しているんだって
言葉だから それは別に気にしなくてもいいんです
何かを認識している 何かを認識しているんだからあるという
だったら神様がいるという
いるあるどちらでもおなじみだから
いるんじゃないんですかね
その場合五感で認識するからというと
神様の場合は想像です
で 五感にしてください
そこはちょっと違う  まあ五感という六感も使ってますけど
で だからそうそうでね
まあ六感という意識で認識するということも同じあるっていうことになっちゃうんで
それでも 認識しているんだから
で 五感といっても五感は単なる物体だから
五感の中に心が働いてないと
目があるんだから見るわけ見られるわけじゃないんだから
やっぱり心が働いてないと
認識の場合は五感プラス心ですよね
そういう意味  で その問題は仏教でどのように解決するかというと
やっぱりこの心にも何かちょっとだけのことを何か触れて
触れたものはあるともう錯覚するんだということで
あるという事態は仏教で認めているわけじゃないんです
あるはないんです あるわけじゃないんです
なぜならばダイナミズムだから
一つも止まってないんだからあると言えないんです
それは仏教の世界であるということ自体もおかしいんです
だから働きでしょう 働きということはもうずっとそれ変化しているということなんですね
変化しなきゃ働きは生まれません
ということは 全ての現象は働きであるならば
一つの現象はあるわけじゃないんです
どうしてもあると言いたければ
この時間から考えて瞬間に絞ると
瞬間だけあるということは
まあどうしても言いたければ言えるんだと
まあそういう まあそれは答えなんですけど
まあ一応このあるという場合も
人々はおかしいことをするんです
例えばこちらで缶コーヒーが私は実際に見たことが見るでしょ
それで私はちらっと店なんかの窓から見たら
宝石屋さんで金の何かアクセサリーを見たとしいます
それでも何か認識しちゃったんですね
私はそちらの認識 それからいろんなところで
例えば金属とかいろいろ見たところで
またその認識もあって
この金属と金の認識を組み合わせちゃう
組み合わせてここで缶コーヒーを認識する
これも金属で認識して
それで私は金の認識をこちらに導入して金の缶
缶コーヒーのことを想像する
それで実際には金の缶コーヒーは我々の実際の認識の世界にはないんです
たとえ誰かが作っても
それはコーヒー入れてこんな風には作れません
ただ置き物としてもう苦労して作るかもしれませんだけど
ですから 実際にこの世の中で
地球ではこうやってこの缶コーヒーの金のものはないんですけど
いとも簡単に認識ができるんです
だからストーリーの世界
物語の世界 いくらでも出来上がっちゃうんですね
こう神秘の世界も全てその心のこのほんのちょっとのこのカラクリで
だから心ほど騙しやすいもの
暗示かけやすいもの マインドコントロールしやすいものはないんで
みんなこっちはこちらのことですけど
信頼できないんですよ
だからみんな 例えば日本の方々は和食は世界一最高だとすぐ言っちゃうし
それもはっきり言えばマインドコントロールだと
中国人は中国料理こそが世界一だと言っちゃうし
それも何のことなくマインドコントロールであるし
日本人が外国旅行に行ったらどうしても蕎麦屋さん探すでしょうし
時々もうかなり長い距離をもう行って行って
一時間二時間でも行って
そこらどうかで蕎麦屋さんがありますからと
言って遠い外国でも 探してた
ああ よかったと 何考えてるかと
日本に帰ったらそこら辺どこでも立ち食いそば屋といっぱいあるのに
だからなんでああいうことを
例えばイタリアに行ったら
イタリア人が自分の料理は長い間作ってきたんだから上手なんです
だから一番美味しいものをイタリアに行って食べたければ
そこら辺の道路であっちこっちで売ってる店で食べた方が一番美味しくていいと思いますけど
でもそうはしないで とにかく日本語ででも看板でも書いてる店探して行っちゃうんですね
だからまあどんな人間でも日本人だけじゃなくて
どんな人間でも同じことなんで
アメリカ人が来たらマクドナルドの看板見たら落ち着く可能性は当然あるし
当然あるわけじゃなくて確実にあるんですから
なぜならば私もよくマクドナルドに行ったりしますから
それでももうヨーロッパ人やら外国人やらみんなもう来ていて
だから私にとってもいくらかは気持ちいいというかね
で 喋るなりに話やらね
いろいろもう できますからね
一人寂しくいるよりは
だから誰かと外国の人と喋りたいなと思ったら
マクドナルドさんとかそこに行けばほとんど見つかるんです
ですから みんな同じ心の働きなんですね
そこで私はチェックしてみたんです
もう別にチェックしなくてもいいことだけど
もうずっと日本でマクドナルド食べて
それからアメリカで食べるとまるっきり違うんです
看板も同じかもしれませんだけど
全く違う それいい証拠っていうのは
日本人がアメリカに行ったら蕎麦屋さん探すんでやって
マクドナルドみたいな日本でもあるんだから
あちら行って食べましょう
もうわかりますからっていうと
こっちまで毎日のように行ってるんだから安心して行けるんだけど
行かないんです 行って食べたところで私は思いますけど
口に合わないと思います
向こうのものはあれほど統一されているのに
世界中 試しにシンガポールに簡単に行けるでしょ？行ってマクドナルドさんにあの漢字で書いてますけどね
で ローマ字も時々あります
行って食べてみてください
あれは簡単 はっきり言えばあれは中華料理なんです
あのハンバーガー 日本にあるマクドナルドではないんです
私ももう日本に来て初めて食べたんだから
なぜならば自分の国では当時ではマクドナルドでもなかったし
今も一つ二つ店あるみたいだけど
だから私のマクドナルドの基準は日本のマクドナルドの基準なんです
それで私はアメリカに行って食べてみたら
ああ なんだ これは嫌だ
食べられないなと なんだこの味って感じになりましたから
それでシンガポール行った時
これも中華料理 嫌だから来たのにと
それはどういう心の働きでしょうかね
このダブっちゃう このカンコーヒーは金のカンコーヒーにそうそうする働きと同じなんです
すぐもう他々の認識持ってきてダブって合成しちゃうんです
だからアメリカに行ったら
その体に合わないなと思っちゃうのは
日本で食べたマクドナルドの感覚を向こうへ持っていって合成する時なんです
だから私から見れば 外国で売ってる日本料理っていうのはろくなものじゃないんだけど
でも行って喜んでなぜ食べるかというと
その場合は実際の品物の味というよりも
ああ良かった良かったという
自分の子供の時から食べてきた味を持ってきて
そこにもう合成するんです
いわゆる絵に描いた餅なんですね
結局 だから道元禅師のみんな食べてるんだけど
絵に描いた餅 お腹がもうそれで
もう満腹になってるんだからいいんじゃないですかと
だから食べてはいるんだけど
食べてはないという言葉でしょうに
だからその働きはもういつでも我々やってるんですね
まあそれで煩悩が生まれたり
怒りが生まれたり あの
何て言いますか 絶望になったりとかね
もしこの違う認識 また違う現象に持ち運ばないならば
そこにあるのは事実のみ
そこに怒る原因はないんで
怒るためには対象を比較するものはないんだから
欲も作れないんです もう対象するものはないんだから
比較するものがないんだから
だからヴィパッサナーではもう比較しないで
評価しないで 確認だけしてみてくださいっていうのは
その能力を育てるためなんです
何か体験するためではないんです
能力の開発なんです 初めから
そこでもう三番目のパッチパッターナの説明にまた戻ります
このパッチパッターナっていうのは
私はそちらのカンコーヒーですよという瞬間で
私は何を認識したかということ
いわゆるわかりやすく言えば
自分に自分がどのように認識するか
自分がどのように理解する
理解するかということは三番目の立場なんです
四番目の立場は パダッター
パダッターのこっちにはいいと思いますけど
この直接原因 原因は何ですか？だから原因なしに現象が生まれません
何か現象が生まれたということは
何か原因があるんですね
そこでものの原因を探そうとするとキリがない
例えば人に向かってなんであんたの頭が悪いんですかと
本当に悪いんだったら原因があるはずでしょうに
これなんでと聞いたってもこれキリがないんですね
原因を探そうと思ったらキリがなくなっちゃう
それから ある現象にどんな現象も現象になった途端
時間という架空のものなんですけど
成立しちゃうんですね
時間あるわけないんです
時間というものは頭の概念だけで存在しない
でも現象がある限り 時間という架空幻想が成立する
例えば食べ物を作った途端
賞味期限という時間成立するでしょ
それはプラスチックで作った途端
またもう五 六年も使えると
本物を作ったならば もう 1 日限するというふうに
時間というものは現象によって成立しちゃうんですね
それで ある現象 なんでこうなってるんですかと
これ調べると時間の軸で言ってみちゃえば
もうどう永久的に行くんで
現象から現象 現象から現象へと
複雑なんですね 例えば今前言った例を見てください
なぜあなたの頭が悪いんですかと
と聞いても この人は前の日何やったか
次の日じゃない 次のそうやって生まれた時から調べていったってもキリがないでしょうに
それで一つだけじゃないでしょ
原因は その場合に 例えば学校に行った時期に戻ったところ
遡ったところで 学校ではいい先生に恵まれなかったということを見つかったとする
じゃあそれで頭が悪くなったと決められますかね？で
決められません それでなぜならば
悪い先生に出会っても頭がいい人もいるし
だから一つもはっきりしないんですね
親が厳しかったんだからとか
あるいは家が貧しかったんだからとか
まあ子供の時は病気になったとかね
それ一つも決まりの原因じゃないんです
例えば子供の時 病気になったんだから頭が悪かったと言ったっても
子供の時 生まれつき病気の人は頭がすごい鋭くてシャープな人もいるんだから
それなかなか納得いかないんですね
家が貧しかった 冗談じゃない
ものすごい貧しい家で生まれて
すごい頭が立派になってる人もいるんだから
これまた納得いかないんですね
だから仏教は因果法則なんです
この因果法則のこの限りない未定な状態
未定というか この確率ありすぎて
理解しにくい状態 はっきりしない状態
だからこれだけは世の中にある一番難しい哲学だと
因果法則って ということになった
だから あの例は一番いい
なんであんたの頭が悪いんですか？と人に聞いても
本人のことだから 本人の頭が悪いんだから
本人が知ってるはずなんですね
例えば なんであなた骨
足の骨が折ってるんですか？と聞いたら
今度スキーに行ったところで滑っちゃったんだよと
こけちゃったんだとはっきりするでしょ
そういうふうに何ではっきりしないんですかね
それでスキーに行って
滑って転がっちゃって骨が折れたと言っても
あれは正しくはないんです
なぜならば何回もこけちゃうでしょう
でも怪我はしません 時々すっごくもの怖くて
ものずっともうおこって転がって転がって来たっても
何のことなく立ち上がったりする場合もあるし
だから それさえもなんかどこかで納得いかないんですよ
だから何なのですかね
たとえスキーに行って骨が折って帰ってきても
折れて帰ってきても はっきりとこれをこういう原因でということは言えないんです
それぐらい複雑 なんですよ
因果法則っていうのは
だからこの瞑想中はそんな因果法則を発見すると思ったって
もうこれをもう置いといた方がいいんです
その代わりにやるのは